we begin this morning with the real news
the growing firestorm over the revoked
security clearance for former CIA
director John Brennan Brennan is a
fierce critic of President Trump now
there are plans to cancel the clearances
for other officials the president is
facing mounting criticism from the
intelligence community for this
unprecedented action after Brennan's
clearance was revoked this week more
than a dozen high-ranking former
intelligence officials have come to his
defense mr. Trump is spending the
weekend at his New Jersey golf course
Errol Barnett is traveling with the
president
Erol good morning good morning the White
House has drafted additional documents
revoking the security clearances of
current and former intelligence
officials this is according to the
Washington Post and apparently President
Trump is ready to sign them and this
comes as more than 70 former
intelligence officials go public with
their displeasure with the
commander-in-chief the fact that he's
using a security clearance of a former
CIA director as a pawn in his public
relations strategy I think is just so
reflective of somebody who quite frankly
don't want to use this term maybe but
he's drunk on power former CIA director
John Brennan speaking out against
President Trump for revoking his
security clearance retaliation he says
for criticism of the president's
policies and character like this tweet
from July when Brennan called Trump's
performance at a press conference with
Russian leader Vladimir Putin quote
nothing short of treasonous I think this
is just another example of mr. Trump
trying to frighten intimidate others but
I can tell you these are not the type
people who are going to be bullied or
intimidated by someone of the likes of
mr. Trump speaking to reporters while
leaving the White House Friday president
Trump was asked if a current Department
of Justice official should lose his
clearance as some conservatives are
suggesting I think Cruz or is it
disgrace I suspect I'll be taking it
away very quickly in protest 15 former
top intelligence officials from both
Democratic and Republican
administrations went on the record with
their displeasure at the president's
actions saying mr. Trump's motives have
quote everything to do with an attempt
to stifle free speech they are joined by
sixty lower-ranking former CIA officers
who also signed a letter supporting
Brennan and warning that mr. Trump is
threatening the security of the country
I don't talk about that the president
also refused his own advice in publicly
taking sides as jury deliberations were
underway in the federal trial of former
campaign chairman Paul Mann afore he
worked for me for a very short period of
time but you know what he happens to be
a very good person and I think it's very
sad what they've done now the
president's sympathetic words for manna
fort could be a sign of his intention to
pardon him if he is found guilty of any
of the 18 crimes that he's been charged
with as it relates to bank and tax fraud
but even that pardon would have to wait
as manna for next month faces another
trial in Washington DC with the special
counsel announcing it has three times as
much evidence in that case than it had
in Virginia
Elaine Errol Barnett with the president
in New Jersey thank you